before
so
i think at least now you can see the
screen
okay so hello everyone welcome to the
third day of the
okay
bootcamp
today we'll have a day about optimal
transport and nike area accepted
very nicely to give us a talk on a crash
course on summer transport so thank you
michaela
so thank you very much for the
invitation to this very nice problem i'm
honored to give
this short lecture on optimal transport
so it's a crash course so i will cover
quite a lot of basic material but
without entering too much into details
and proof uh i will write on the ipad as
i wear and um let's say as
with the whiteboard i hope you will see
it please if you don't see something
tell me to
to zoom i will do it
so
um the outline of this uh of this
presentation is the following i will
first start with a brief introduction to
the problem of optimum transport
then i will introduce the contravec
duality that is a very important tool in
optimization also
and
then i will arrive to the core of the
optimal transport theory that is
bernie's theorem
is one of the fundamental currents in
the in the theory
then i will pass to the definition of
vassa's time distances vast science
space
and
the goal is to give an informal
introduction to gradient flows in
universal spaces
the benemobrine formula to finally
arrive to a formal introduction of
otoscalcus
to to show that the heat equation is the
gradient flow in vaseline on the end of
the entropy
can you hear me well
yes
okay perfect
so let me just give you some references
some are quite classical there are two
books
by cedric villani one is topics in
optimal transportation is the first one
he wrote in 2003
then i read uh some parts of these books
by ambrosio gilia savare that is about
gradient flows in particular gradient
flow symmetric spaces and in the space
of probability measures
so it's a very very complete
let's say reference on running flows
much more than much much more than what
i would say today
then more recently there have been
this contribution by felipe santambrogio
that is called optimal transport for
applied mathematicians so
that is centered in the topic
and then kuturi pereira wrote
in 2018 a book on computational optimum
transport
and finally figali claudo wrote a book
that is called an invitation to optimum
transport buses and distances and
gradient flows in 2021 and this is
let's say a very introductory book to
the topic so um
if you then will need
more uh precise references just let me
know and i can provide some more
detailed
um
references but in in all these
essentially in all these books you will
find what i will
talk about today in a way or another
so
i'm trying to move okay
so let me start with a very brief
overview
um
okay can you see well
so the the problem of optional
transportation uh has been first
introduced by gas per month a french
mathematician is actually a french
engineer in um
in 1781
uh
in a way just to to to answer to a very
practical question the question is
um assume
uh one extracts soil from the one from
the ground to be fortification
what is the cheapest possible way to
transport the soil so imagine that like
here we have this amount of the
of soil that we want to extract and we
want to to bring it to to build a
fortification so we want to transport
in a sense uh here we don't have
probability measure we don't see
probability measures but we can think
that this distribution of soil is
distributed
like
a probability measure mu
and this construction this building is a
probably identity new
and we want to find the the cheapest
possible way to to bring
this mass from one place to the other
and cheapest
in which sense so to formulate this
question rigorously one needs to specify
how much one pays to to move a unit of
mass from the point x
that i pictured here to the point y
and in one case the ambient space was r3
and the cost was simply uh the euclidean
distance so the travel this the travel
distance
now this this was the most
classical formulation of optimal
transport
um then many many years passed by until
leonid kantorovich in 19 in the 40s
essentially in the 49th of last century
proposed a new let's say more
modern
version of the optimal transport problem
in mo
let me remark that in munch
formulation the optimal transport
problem is deterministic so i'm saying
that there is just one point
where
where the point the mass that is in x
can only go
in a point that is y equal t of x
okay
uh in the 1940s
uh
kantorovich instead proposed a different
a different notion of optimal transport
that could uh take into account some
non-deterministic situation that are
very common in real life let me present
it uh with an example
so suppose that we have um several
bakeries uh b1bn here i pictured three
bakeries because b1 b2 and b3 are at the
bakeries
and several coffee shops c1 c2 c3 and c4
so
in let's say cj goes from one to one
these
bakeries are located at points x x i
and they sell a quantity of bread that
is
alpha i let me let me write it
so this is
bread
produced
by b1
and this is the position
i mean the the label that i do to this
to this bakery
let's say
label so uh these coffee shops instead
are in positions b um
y y y i
and they buy a quantity of bread that is
by a beta beta j so let me now
change
so
i hope you can you can still see see
well
so
okay
alpha i
larger than zero
is the amount of bread
produced
by the bakery bi
beta j larger than 0 is the amount of
bread
that
is bought
needed
by
the coffee shop cj
so we assume
the first assumption is that the offer
is equal to the to the demand
so the demand is sum
from j that is equal from 1 to m
of beta j and after is sum from i that
goes from 1 to n of alpha
i
and we normalize everything to 1
because we we want to deal with
probability measure in the end
so now this problem is incompatible with
munch formulation because each bakery
may supply bread to multiple coffee
shops and one coffee shop made by bread
from multiple bakeries
so for this reason controversy
introduced
a new cost formulation so given
c of x i
y j
this is the cost
to move
one unit of mass
from
x i
to yj
it looks
for matrices
gamma i j
either goes from 1 to n and j that goes
from 1 to m
um such that we we ask for the for the
following assumption um
a
gamma i j is it large enough i am
yes
okay
um gamma j is larger than zero that
means that the amount of bread going
from x i to y j is non-negative
b
for for every i
sum over j that goes from 1
to m
of gamma i j is equal to alpha i that
means that the total amount of bread
sent to the different coffee shop is
equal to the production
c for all j
we have that sum
from from i that goes from 1 to n gamma
j
is equal to beta j
so the total amount of bread
both from the difference bakery is equal
to the demand
and finally d
that gamma j
minimizes
the total cost
that is
sum over i j from 1
to n
and then gamma i j c of x i
y
j so
okay so the total transport cost is
minimized
so it's interesting to observe that the
constraint a
is a convex constraint
while um b c and d are linear with
respect to gamma j
so linear so in a sense we are just
trying to
minimize
a linear
a linear problem with convex or linear
constraint
so this is already this already shows a
bit why this
this formulation can be very handy let
me just come back one second to the
picture just to show here i pictured a
quick example and i show you how to
compute
the gamma ij so for example gamma 33
is alpha 3 because the bakery b3 only
sells
bread to c3
and gamma 2 3
is beta 3 minus alpha 3
because it has to
to compensate the fact that the coffee
shop number three
um receives bread also from the bakery
b3
is it clear this simple example can i
go
so i assume yes so if there are no
question i go on
so
optimal transport has attracted a lot of
interest
uh over over the years in application
due to its connection to several areas
of mathematics
and in particular these all the
applications are heavily linked to the
geometry and also to the choice of the
cost function c of x and y
so for example let me just mention few
applications
so there have been applications to the
study of the euler equation
sub isomeric isoparametric inequality
sobolev inequality
etc but also
in in the study of evolution please
like um
for us medium equations or detail view
this is this bullet equal to lambda of u
to the m
or
dtu equal divergence
of graph w convolution u
and so on um
and for example
in these situations the the most common
commonly used cost is the quadratic cost
so c of x y equal to
x minus y square or for example so
energy is in inner d
or also um
c of x y equal x minus y
to the p will be strictly larger than
one
but also there have been several
applications to probability
and to kinetic theory
so kinetic theory is my main let's say
area of research and so for example
the optimal transport in particular with
the cost
either c of x y equal x minus y or with
the quadratic cost
x minus y squared
have been used a lot for the study of
transfer equilibrium for kinetic
equations or for stability for example
for for the glass of poisson equation
and to study the derivation
of this equation
for plasma physics from the n particle
models so
it's a very useful tool and also for the
study
of richie
curvature or romanian manifold
and here the cost
is still quadratic but is
in most cases
the
the
the imagine distance d of x y square
okay
so of course there are much more
applications but um
i'm sure we will see plenty of
application in the in the next lectures
let me now
uh
go on on with the with the notation so
the notation i'm using is really
classical you have already seen it in in
previous lectures but just for
simplicity so for simplicity
um i will focus on the case of the
euclidean quadratic cost for most of the
time so
cost
equal
x minus y square
honor d so this will be our model case
and in particular i'll do
i will consider the case of rd
in general i indicate by x the space
where the source measure lives
and the source measure is
indicated most of the time by mu
and y is the space
where is the target measure
that is mostly indicated by nu
so
you think about the case x equal to y
equals 30 and another important notation
is p of x that is the set
of probability measures
over x
so let me start now
with several um
basic definitions
so the most important definition will be
the one of transport map but to define a
transport map let me first define a push
forward
so definition
push forward measure
so let
t
from x to y
then
mu is in p of x
new
uh no mu is in p of x
we define the image measure or push
forward the measure
t
push forward mu
in p
of y
such that
t push forward
mu
of a
is
mu of the pre-image
of a
for all a border sets
in y let me explain with a with a
picture
uh in the case of transport map
so um if now mu is in p of x
and nu
is
in p of y
a map
d from x to y
is called
a transport map
if
t push forward mu is equal to mu so let
me show uh with the picture this so
this is x
this is the space y this is the measure
mu
and this is the measure nu
so
we take
a border set
in u this is a
so t
cell sends new onto mu
so
t is a transport map
if we have that
t is the push forward of mu on new and
the condition is that
mu
gives
to the to the bottle set
t minus 1 of a
the same weight let's say the same mass
that
nu gives to the ball set a
okay
so
the natural
the natural
first question that we have to ask
ourselves is whether these transport
maps always exist or no and
unfortunately
uh one of the main problem we will see
one of the main
problem
in mont formulation compared to
controversy for to the controversy
formulation is that optimal transport
map and transport map in general don't
always exist so remark
so given
mu and nu
the set
of maps
such that
t push forward mu is equal to new so the
set of transport map from mu to nu
may be empty
think for example to the case of mu
equal delta in x0 so if mu
is
lo is a delta
mu
is necessarily the
direct delta
in key of x0 so unless
a new
nu
is a direct delta
then the set
of transport map
from newton new
is empty
okay
so uh let me now uh
go on to another fundamental definition
um
that is that
is the one that will be uh
used to define the counter of each
problem in of optional transport and
this is a definition of coupling or
transport plan so definition
or transport plan
so the term coupling is mostly used in
probability but
we can use both term
we can use both term
so we call
gamma
a measure in the
in the product space
x times y
a coupling
of mu and u
if
if mu is the first marginal of gamma and
nu is the second marginal of gamma that
means
that
the push forward
of gamma
the push forward of gamma
with the with the first projection is mu
and
pi y push forward gamma is new
so pi x is the function
that associate to the point x y x so
it's the projection of the first
variable and pi y
is the projection of the second variable
um
so here let me do another picture
so suppose so
this is gamma
this is x and this is y
and if we take
the projection
by x
of gamma
we will find mu
and if we take
the projection
[Music]
the projection
by y of gamma
we will find new
and this is this is fundamental for
for for what we will say in the
following so i recall that gamma is a
measure on the product space
so we denote by
gamma
of mu and nu
the set of all couplings
of you and you
okay
so now
an important remark
is that
given
mu and u
the set
gamma of nu nu
is always not empty
for example
the measure mu tensor nu
is an admissible cutting so it's a
coupling of mu and u
so belongs to gamma of nu
and this um
is another big difference with the
notion of transport map that
a coupling between two measures always
exist while the transport map from to
measure is not always
necessary that it exists
so
again on this subject of transport map
versus transport couplings
so
it's important to note that
if
t
from x to y is a transport map from u to
nu so satisfies that he pushed forward
mu is equal to nu
then
there is a natural way to induce
to induce a
a transport coupling between your new
using the map t
so we consider
the map
identically times t
that goes from x to x times y and
associate to x
the graph of t
then
gamma t
defined
it's
the push forward of mu
of the push forward of identity times t
of the of the measure mu
is a probability measure on next time y
and belongs
to gamma of nunu so it's a coupling
uh so any transport map and use a
coupling gamma t
this is another fundamental notion and
this was covering essentially the the
basic definitions that we needed to now
uh be able to to to explain mongen
pandorovich formulations for for optimum
transport
so
command
so assume now again
in p of x
new input y
assumed c to be the cost
um that goes from x times y
you assume the cost to be bounded from
below
and continuous
so now a little disclaimer i will um
i will only mention
theorems and formulation in the in the
most
let's say in the easiest possible
setting but
several things can be relaxed
and uh putting greater to reality but
for simplicity i will just talk about
continuous cost here
so
the margin control which problems can be
stated that follows so the total
launch transportation cost between mu
and u
is the infimum
on all transport maps of the integral on
x of c of x t of x
d mu of x
so the infimum is taken on all the
transport maps from mu to nu
and i will call this m so this is the
monge problem while the current the
counter of each problem so the the total
kantorovich transport cost
between mu and u
is the initial on all the transport
plans
of this quantity that is integral
on x x time y
c of x y
the gamma of x y
such that gamma is a coupling between mu
and u and you see also that um the
counter of each problem is much more
symmetric than the demand one so there
are a lot of indication that solving the
counter of each problem uh is easier
than solving munch problem
um
in fact
for example already one problem consists
of minimizing the transportation costs
among all transport maps and this set of
transport map we have seen that can be
empty
while control which consists in
minimizing on a set is never empty for
example
so we call optimal transport map so
optimal
transport
map
or coupling
the map or coupling that realizes
um
cm or ck
so
slash copy
okay
so now we have
a definition of
transport map and optimal transport
coupling another remark
is that
we know that if
if t push forward mu is equal to new
then
the associated coupling gamma key
can be taken considering the graph of
the push forward mu
and in addition
t
and gamma t at the same cost
before
the total amount cost between mu and nu
is always larger or equal
to the total contraption cost
okay
now some natural questions at this point
um consist in asking whether minimizers
exist so
do minimizers
of um
okay
exist
and if yes
can we characterize them
so can we say something about the
structure
and let me start uh
from the existence of an optimal
coupling from what i have already
mentioned in general solving the counter
of each problem is easier than solving
demand problems so also for existence
a strategy a natural strategy is to
first prove existence of an optimal
coupling and then try to put of to to to
prove existence for
of an optimal transport map
so theorem
so
let's c
at a cost that is bounded from below
and continues
uh mu in p of x
nu in p y
then there exists an optimal coupling
gamma
and then
once we have existence the the second
uh natural question is about uniqueness
so is gamma bar unique
and
if in general we have found
this uh this optimal coupling
we know that every transport map can use
a coupling but here we can ask ourselves
is
gamma bar induced
by transport mod
so in general um just to have some
intuition of this uh
about the possible answer to this
question let me give you uh a couple of
examples
so just to um
okay so examples
okay assume that
mu
is a delta
in x0 so we have x0
and we have
a delta so we have mass 1 here
and nu
is one half
delta y zero plus one half delta y one
so there are other two points y zero and
y one
and here we have mass one alpha and mass
one off so there is only let's say
the only thing that we can do is to send
from x zero one alph to a zero and one
alpha to y one
so
it exists unique a minimizer
that is gamma bar equal to one alpha
delta x0 y0
plus one half
delta of x0 y1
but of course as we said this is not
induced by transport node
so we already answered to the to the
second question that is not let's say
it's not necessarily induced by a
transport map
second example
we assume x equal to y equal to r2
the cost is quadratic
and let's put four points so
um
x one is in zero zero
x two is in one one
then we have
okay this should be one one
one 1 0 y 1 is in a 1 0
and y 2
is in
0 1
so
and
suppose that mu is now
one half
delta x one plus one alpha delta x two
and u is one alpha delta in y1 plus one
half delta in y2
so how can we send
new on to nu
so
we can start from x1 and we can say okay
let's now send
a quantity alpha
in zero one off
in way one
say include and then
we send the rest so one half minus alpha
to y2 and let's do the same
from x1 so here we send alpha
still in zero one off
and then we send the remainder
one alpha
minus alpha
on y one
so we see that
the the the couplings given by
alpha delta x one
y one
plus
one alpha minus alpha
delta uh
x one
y two
plus uh
one half minus alpha
delta
x2
y1
plus alpha delta of x2 a2
with alpha in zero one off
these are all optimal so these are
all
optimal couplings
um
and this rules out the uniqueness
without further assumption and this was
in a sense predictable because
the control of each problem is a linear
optimization problem of over a set with
the convex constraint or linear
constraint so a priori since the problem
is linear in
gamma
there is no reason to expect
uniqueness without any further let's say
hypothesis
and this um
is what i wanted to say about optimal
transport maps and document transport
problems and about the existence of an
optimal transport
coupling and let me now present uh very
briefly the controversiality that is a
very powerful tool from both the
theoretical and numerical point of view
so i will not
directly use the controversiality today
because simply because i'm not entering
in the proof
but
you will probably see
dual problems in the following lectures
i will give first uh the general theorem
of controversiality
but also the version that was originally
proposed by kantorowicz for the distance
cost function
because that version is
is really simple and useful
so um
let me now go to
control virtuality
um
so as many of you know
um if you have a linear minimization
problem with convex constraint in
general it admits a dual problem uh that
if formulated
as a
as a maximization problem
and this is just because of now theorems
in uh in convex analysis
so
in this specific case
we have c
the cost
continuous
bounded from below
and now assume
that the if
on gamma
coupling between mu and u
so this is essentially the the control
which
the contour of each problem uh i'm sorry
this is not the x this is the gamma
is finite
then
we can reformulate this problem in the
following way so we can this is our
primal problem
i'm
sorry let me write it below actually
so we have that the minimum
on gamma in capital gamma mu nu
of the integral of c d gamma this is our
primal
problem
this is equal to the max
on
v of x
plus
c of y
plus
c of x
y
larger than zero
we'll put the plus here just to show
that it's the same equation
of
integral of minus phi d mu
plus integral of minus c
d nu
and this is our
dual problem
so we can transform a minimization
problem or in a maximization problem and
you can see that now for example
um
you have that new and new
in the primal problem appear
[Music]
because the they are
uh
they are in the minimization so
we are minimizing on the on the
couplings between new and new while here
they appear
in in the in the in what i'm minimizing
so in the
in the integrals and at the same and in
the same way the cost in the primal
problem
is in the integral while here the cost
is now in the constraint and this is
very common in
in in convex in convex analysis but let
me now show
the special case that was
some special case
that was introduced by contravich
himself
so again we have x equal to rt and now
the cost
is
x minus y
so the euclidean distance
then
the minimum
on gamma
we're
coupling between mu and u
of integral
on x times y
of the
euclidean distance between
x minus x and y
in the gamma
this is equal to the max
over
fee
of all
v1 lip sheets function
of what of integral over x of v
[Music]
integral
over y of phi d nu minus integral over x
of v
d mu
and by one leap sheets i mean simply
that
f of x minus phi of y
is smaller than
x minus y for all
x y
in x so it just slips it with constant
one
um
and this uh
contravic controversiality in the case
of uh
the cost x minus x minus y
it is very simple so it was really
widely used in particular let me mention
that um
this uh this controversiality played a
big role in uh
improves in kinetic theory because one
of the first proofs uh that used uh
optimal transport in kinetic theory has
been
the proofs of um
mean field limit in the case of loss of
equation of um and in general the world
poseness of plasma equation by brushing
that in the 70s used
this
the the bounded leap sheets um
distance or the one vases and distance
and in general this controversiality
uh
to show that
if you have a two solution of this
equation of this class of equation then
you have stability
and this was very useful since then
by the way the brushing was also the
person who
who assigned the name of basses time
distances to the distances of optimal
transport and this was a bit unfair
because actually kantorovich introduced
uh those distances but the brushing at
the time was not aware of his obvious
work so the
culprit of why we really use
vases and distances instead of
controvedge distances
and
let me now
go on
so we are now ready
for for the bright theorem
that
is really a cornerstone of the optimal
transport theory i will state the
benefit only for quadratic cost even if
it applies also more generally to
several strictly convex costs but let me
state it in the simplest possible way
so let
x be equal to y
be rd
the cost
be quadratic
suppose
that
the integral of
rb
of x squared nu
plus integral over rd of y square
dnu
is not infinite so
then
assume
that mu is absolutely continuous with
respect to the bed measure
then
we can say that there exists
a unique optimal transport coupling
and moreover what we can say is that
gamma bar
is actually induced by a map
so is
induced by map t
t now is an optimal transport map but on
top of that we have a we have a
structure that is
the t is the gradient
of v
for feet
convex
so not only we have an optimum transport
coupling but we have that the coupling
is induced by the map and that the map
has actually a lot of structure because
it's the gradient of the convex function
and you know that convexity in in
optimization problem is is really
a key key
let's say
feature
and in particular the fact
that
the optimum transport maps are gradient
of something so the role of the of the
gradients of functions
is really central in in the optimal
transporter and we will see it also when
i will formally introduce autocalculus
so um
there is as i said there is an analog
for the cost
x minus y to the p with p strictly
larger than one
in this case we have to require
that we have bounded p moments
so instead of the power two we shall
have done here the power p
and
here and
in that case we have existence and
uniqueness of an optimal coupling gamma
bar
and we still induced this gamma bar by
by some transport t but in this case t
is not the gradient of the convex
function that is more complicated it
comes with a more complicated formula
that is less useful in general than the
one that we have in the quadratic course
so
let me give you now another definition
so
we want to arrive to the definition of
bus sustained distance
so first we need to define
the problem the space of probability
measures with the finite pmos the p in
the moment
so
oops
big d measures
with finite p moment
so again let x equal rt
let p be
in one plus infinity
then we call
capital p of p of x
the set of all probability measures on x
sigma
such that the integral over x
of
x to the power p
in the sigma of x is finite
so this is also referred to as moment
condition so this is
okay
and now that we have the space
that will be the protagonist of the
following i can finally define um
the vases and distances
so definition
p passes time distance
probably will change pages
[Music]
so um
givens given now
to measures mu and nu
in the space of probability measures on
x with finite p moment
then the p vases and distance between mu
and u is defined
we take the infimum on all the couplings
between mu and
mu of what of the integral
or next time
time y
oops in this case is
x
of x minus y
to the power p
the gamma
of x and y
to the power one over p
so we see that is this is
the power one over p
of the optimal
transport cost by control which
so we have that
the relation of these distances with the
optimum transport problem is very
crystal clear
because it's really
it's really defined in this way
and
it's not very easy to prove in
particular the triangular inequality but
we can prove that the p vases and
distance
so the w
so vs time p
is a distance
on the space
of probability measures on x with finite
p moment so we will refer
at
um
to pp of x
with the distance by system ps by system
space
and these passes and distances
are really exceptionally useful and
in many sense uh easy to to to work with
in particular in the case
of the two buses in the distance and of
the one buses and distance that i use it
for for different
um situations uh in particular
a very nice feature of the buses and
distances is that a very weak norm but
we have this this theorem
that tell us that suppose that we are in
a compact set for for simply doing we
set everything in compact sets
then
so p larger than one if we have mu nu
mu n
a sequence of probability measures
on x
and mu
a probability measure
on x
then we have that
the vastest time distance the devices
and distance is equivalent
to the weak star convergence
so saying
that mu1
weekly start converse to mu
in this case is equivalent to say
that the piva sustained distance between
new and new
tends to zero
so
uh on compact sets the buses and
distance
convergence is equivalent to the weak
star convergence and and this is also a
reason why the these distances are very
practical with respect to other
distances between probability measures
think also about the simple fact that um
for example if you if you have 2d two
direct deltas
centered at two two points x0 and x1 if
you consider for example
the total variation distance between
these two uh deltas the total dash
distance is always equal to two
no matter how close are the supports of
these deltas while the vases and
distance instead
uh between two beta
[Music]
is uh essentially the the euclidean
distance between
uh the support of the dead as you can do
this as an exercise so it's a it's a
it's a distance that is um very
sensitive also to atomic measures and
this is uh great for for many
applications
for example this is great in in kinetic
theory when you one want to derive
equations from particle models
so but come back to optimum transport
we now
are left
for this first hour with the
construction of geodesics
so
x now is again equal to rt
assume that mu 0 and mu1
are probability measure on x
so we have mu 0
we have mu1
and we want to construct
so we have a transport map t
and we want to construct
a geodesic so we want to in a way
interpolate
mu0 and mu1
using
this this optimal transport map t
okay
so
if t
is the
optimal transport map
between
mu and new
i'm sorry
new zealand new one in this case it's
easier
new one
then the judasic
push forward mu zero
where this map t t is the linear
interpolation between the identity map
and t so t t
of x
is defined as one over t minus t
x minus t
t of x
so in
and so by judassic
we can always have in mind if we want to
think about the judaism between two
points is the shortest path between
these two points informally
and
with this definition of of judasic
we can say that
in this case
that t is an optimal transport map the
jose the jurassic mu t is also said to
be a constant speed judaism so
the judaic
it's mu t is constant speed
that means
that if you take the viva system
distance
between mu s and mu t
this is t minus s
the vases time distance between mu 0
and u1
for all s and t
between
0 and 1.
and
okay i've not mentioned here but mu t
are all measures in the space
uh p
p of x so the space of probability
measure with finite p moment
and uh let me briefly mention that in
the case that we don't have at our
disposal so it doesn't exist an optimum
transport map there is also an a formula
that is equivalent but in the case of um
having an optimal coupling so
a formula that is expressed in terms of
the coupling
and i i don't really know with the delay
at the beginning how much time i had but
i can stop here for this first hour and
um
then we can start again
with the introduction to guardian flows
okay thanks nicaragua
is there any questions
maybe i have one just on the vernier
serum like the
when you have a
cost which uh which is strictly convex
function of x minus y so you said that
we have the
existence of the transport map but that
is not necessarily yeah
the gradient of the context function
right so
yes
so
when is this straight only for the two
so in this case um
so if the cost between x and y is
for example x minus y to the power p
which is strictly larger than 1
then we don't have the t is the gradient
of the convex function but
we have something like t is equal to
grad fee
modulus of graph e uh p minus two
with um v
t conducts something like that
all right uh um i'm i'm not really
really sure of the formula but there is
a formula that that relates
uh the optimum transport map with
gradient
of of functions
again so you're welcome
good question so
thank you um we'll be back at 11 15 um
because we're a bit late on the schedule
sorry for that but let's meet again
no thanks to you
see you soon bye